merci madame la
Présidente quelques motsi au nom de le
groupe socialiste va voter l'ensemble
des amendements qui sont présentés et
notamment suis présenté par le groupe
centriste et d'ailleurs je je note avec
beaucoup de courage la constance qui qui
vous anime chers collègues vous avz fait
cette i lors du PLFR cet été et vous
continuez donc je vous maintenez votre
votre amendement je vous en remercie je
voulais monsieur le ministre je je
voulais aussi rebondir sur ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure sur les super
dividendes en disant que ça posait un
problème de constitutionnalité par
rapport à l'impôt je pense que la taxe
sur les superprit résou en grande partie
cette cette difficulté je vais pas
répéter ce qui été dit je voudrais quand
même rebondir sur le sur la construction
européenne notamment sur l'Europe et je
note que plus que jamais cette
construction européenne est salvatrice
pour notre pays dans ces temps troublés
cette grande Europe monsieur le ministre
vous lui devez beaucoup c'est grâce à
elle que le ministre de l'Économie a pu
découvrir et comprendre ce qui était un
super profit sans l'intervention
européenne il déclarait ne pas savoir ce
qui était un super
profit je suis heureux de noter que
l'Europe lui a permis d'y voir plus
clair sur le sujet c'est encore et
toujours grâce à cette grande Europe que
l'idée d'une taxation de ces super
profits enfin définies vous est apparu
acceptable je tiens donc à remercier
l'Europe qui a mis fin à votre
cécité dans sur ce
sujet d'ailleurs je note qu'il est quand
même très
regrettable que sur ces sujets qui sont
pant
structurant pour notre société que la
voix de la France soit cantonnée à celle
de simple caisses d'enregistrement de
décision supranational pour lesquelles
vous êtes originalement
opposé donc
accepte cette proposition de taxation
c'est enfin je pense force de
proposition et non plus être un éternel
suiveur perpétuellement à rebour de
l'époque